are you doing today sir
I'm terrible obviously yeah look at this
I gotta tell you the matte paintings
that Fox came up with are amazing
we got the star wars team yeah give us
some matte babies this worked out great
they're really talented yeah I gotta
agree with you on that um I can't
believe this is the back lot
um being serious for a second your movie
comes out in October and I know that
there's gonna be a lot of twists and
turns
how have you been describing what would
you like because it's still early and I
normally people might know everything
about a movie but how would how would
you like to describe the film to people
without revealing too much I tend to
describe bad times at the El Royale as a
love letter to the crime thriller I
always wanted to do a film noir or
something in that space and it's it
combines to my love of that and big
ensemble casts you I spoke to you last
for cabin in the woods and I was asking
how long was gonna take to direct
another project and you have made a
great career out of screenwriting but
not directing what was it about this
material that said yeah I'm gonna get
back in the chair I don't know you just
sort of it's all gut it's all you just
go on your instincts the thing about
directing is it's to two to three years
of your life so you really have to be it
for me it has to be very personal and a
story about something I'm very
passionate about in which case this one
was and I'm not the truth is I'm not a
disgruntled screenwriter of a very
fortunate and excited screener I still
love being a screenwriter and working
with directors like Ridley Scott I hope
I get to do stuff like that forever the
footage we saw last night there is a you
showed us one sequence with Jon Hamm and
a tracking shot that was unbelievable
and I'm curious if you could describe to
people or could you couldn't reveal are
there were a lot of shots in the movie
that are that intense with you know five
minutes of non like no cutting or is it
was that you know what I mean like what
was it about let's jump with that yeah
certainly this shot we showed you is in
our top five most ambitious shots if not
our number one I'm not sure but I know I
knew very early I wanted to be very
ambitious visually with the movie and I
hired Seamus McGarvey who is very
familiar with aggressive camera moves he
did the atonement shot if you don't know
that go check it out and it was just so
special as a director of photography and
it was very much the language I wanted
to employ while shooting this film well
the shot that I'm specifically bringing
up with you as Jon Hamm learning about
the hotel early in the movie from what I
understand it took 27 takes and eight
months of planning yeah it was it was
one of those things where if I had known
better I probably would have made it
easy on myself and not done it but
naivete is a real weapon and I knew
there's a certain elements that make the
shot particularly difficult one of which
was I needed
Cynthia Revo to sing live the entire
time while we were while the shot was
taking place so that that brought with
it its own difficulties because not only
did we have to figure out how to do the
shot we also had to figure out to do the
shot silently because no one could make
noise so we could record her sound which
we had to create a whole bunch of
different baffling for both the camera
and the crew so that everyone could move
in unison silently that took a lot of
research and development that's crazy
yeah it's bananas uh talk a little bit
you'll Jake II know doing the soundtrack
how tricky was it to get him was it a
phone call or a text it was pretty easy
look Michael and I go way back Michael
and I were on alias together we were on
lost together I've known him over a
decade now and it's been fun to sort of
come up together in the the JJ Abrams
alumni fellowships but so yeah I know I
knows how much I adore him whenever I
have anything I call him it's usually
about schedule when it comes to Michael
because he's very busy turns out when
you're one of the greatest composers in
the world that everyone wants you but he
really sparked to this one and really
excited to
I'm already out of time I will just say
one more let's do one more um I do have
one more question are you actually I
know that your next project is some
superhero movie some indie at Fox sure I
have to ask you where you're at in the
process of that while you're also
finishing up this yeah I've learned that
I'm very much a 1 film at a time kind of
guy and so I've been very focused on
getting bad times done we when this
movie comes out I'll call it mr.
Reynolds and we'll keep the gang
together and start start figuring out
what we want to do completely I cannot
wait and I cannot wait to see this thank
you so much sir thank you so much
you